how's it going everyone it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
marvel all things super and everything
relating to the mcu
now for a while we've had a pretty big
drought in content
not a lot has really happened in the
marvel cinematic universe and
not much has happened with movies in
general however the falcon
and the winter soldier production has
begun again the crew is on set there are
now leaked videos that you can see
of the set and it seems like marvel
studios is officially beginning
production on
a lot of different projects they had to
postpone and one of those is the wanda
vision series a very anticipated marvel
series that is coming to disney plus and
a series that fans have
a lot of questions about like what is it
actually going to be about
well as it turns out marvel has actually
kind of told us what this series is
going to be about they've told us a few
different plot points of this series
now you have to know a little bit about
the comic story lines to know what
you're going to see
in this series but i'll break down the
four stories that you need to know from
the comics and talk about what way we'll
see them
in the one division series if you're new
to the channel don't forget to subscribe
to stay up to date on all the latest
marvel news and so you can enter this
week's giveaway for a chance to win
a gladiator hulk funko pop just
subscribe like the video and leave a
comment down below
so not too long ago only about a year
ago which seems crazy to think about now
disney plus launched now of course they
have a ton of
marvel content on there including a good
majority of the mcu films
a ton of different shows live action and
animated and they also produced some new
content
and one of those was a documentary
called expanding
the universe and in this documentary we
learned that the wanda vision series is
going to be based off of several
different famous comic books these four
comic book series include the iconic
house of m series the scarlet witch run
by james robinson
the vision and the scarlet witch and the
vision run by tom king
now the fact that these four comic books
are going to make up
what we see in the one division series
that actually means that we know a lot
about what to expect
and knowing all of these stories about
the scarlet witch and vision and knowing
that they're all about to be combined
into a tv
show makes this show one of the most
exciting marvel projects ever done
and if you don't know the stories don't
worry i'm about to go over them all
we'll first start off with the scarlet
witch run by james robinson
now this run is very very new it's about
four to five years
old but this comic was very different
because typically the scarlet witch
comics focused on her
and somebody else like her brother or
vision but this particular comic was
all about her and it focused on the
witchcraft
world this comic run was all about her
going around the world to investigate
the mystery of what's gone wrong with
the witchcraft in the marvel universe
and while she does this she also
discovers where she came from and her
larger place in the occult
corner of the marvel universe and we've
already seen this with some leaked
photos we've seen leaked photos of
agatha harkness and
the salem witches so we already know
where the influence from this run is
going to be in the one division series
they're going to explore more of the
occult more of the actual witchcraft
side and marvel studios has already said
that for the very first time in the mcu
we're actually going to hear wanda be
called the scarlet witch so it seems
very clear that at some point in time
in this series one is going to focus
more on her actual
witchcraft abilities which will be
interesting to see considering the fact
that she got her powers from
the mind stone the next comic we have is
the vision
and i'm also going to tie in vision
quest as well as we've heard that the
show will be loosely based on that as
well
the vision quest is all about wanda
going to assemble the parts of vision
and put him back together
something that we will most likely see
in the show but we actually don't really
know where vision is after the events of
avengers infinity war we know that sword
is going to play a role in the one
division series and we haven't exactly
found out why yet but perhaps
this is why perhaps they're the actual
holders of vision's body right now or
perhaps they're going to help the
scarlet witch find him so the vision
quest is about juan defining vision but
then
in the vision run it's about vision
wanting to be human
and wanting a family so in this run
vision wants to be a human and he wants
a family so he goes back to the very
beginning
the laboratory where ultron created him
as a weapon
here he imagines that he could be more
than what he is he could be an
actual man and have an actual family so
he creates his family he creates a wife
virginia
he creates teenage twins viv and
vin they both look like him and they
have his powers
and they share his desires to become an
actual human
now considering the fact that the wanda
vision series is going to be about wanda
and vision i don't think vision will
actually create
a new family but i do think that he will
want to be human and he'll want a family
and for the promos of the wan division
series we have seen vision as an actual
human
now we did see this in avengers infinity
war he was able to change himself partly
into a human but he wasn't actually
human he just changed his appearance
but vision is coming back in the one
division series we've already seen it in
the tiny little teaser that we got for
it
and it's very clear that vision and
wanda will want kids and will actually
have
them but here's where things are going
to get really crazy and here's why the
show is going to be so exciting
things start to get pretty intense in
the vision in the scarlet witch run
and in the house of mrun so in volume 1
of the vision and the scarlet witch
magneto is actually the father of the
scarlet witch and her brother
quicksilver now in 2014 marvel would go
on to change this and say that magneto
wasn't actually their father
but for about 30 years in the marvel
universe magneto was the father of the
scarlet witch and quicksilver
and in the first volume of the vision
and the scarlet witch magneto plans to
give up his villainous life
then in the second volume the scarlet
witch actually gets pregnant but she
doesn't get pregnant from vision because
he's an android but it's actually magic
that gets her pregnant and she ends up
having two twin boys
wiccan and speed who of course are
already confirmed to come
in the one division series but
unfortunately her story with her twin
boys in the comics takes a darker turn
leading up to the house of m event we
discover that her boys aren't
actually real it's simply wanda using
her reality warping abilities to make it
seem like she has kids but whenever her
and vision leave to fight with the
avengers the boys disappear
however they weren't entirely unreal and
wanda is able to bring them to true life
using her powers and soul fragments of
the demon mephisto
now unfortunately when mephista would
return he would want his soul fragments
back taking away the children of wanda
and vision and this is where it gets
really rough for wanda
wanda has a mental breakdown and she
tries to warp reality to recreate her
lost children
and what happens is the scarlet witch
and professor xavier end up creating the
house of
m reality in this reality wanda has her
boys back and she's able to be with her
father
magneto and her brother quicksilver this
reality grants everybody their deepest
wishes magneto rules this reality ruler
over mutants
and humans spider-man is a celebrity
married to gwen stacy
and wolverine is an agent of shield and
this reality becomes the main reality
for a little bit
and none of the heroes the avengers or
the x-men can seem to remember the
previous reality except
for wolverine so he goes and he tells
the avengers
meanwhile professor xavier meets with
them as well and they decide together
that they have to kill wanda
quicksilver finds out about this and he
runs and he tells magneto here
the x-men and the avengers attack the
house of m the scarlet witch
quicksilver and their father magneto it
is soon revealed to magneto that this
world is a lie and it's not real it was
created by his daughter the scarlet
witch and he freaks out in anger
he ends up killing his son quick silver
but suddenly wanda appears and brings
quicksilver back to life
she looks at her dad lashing out and
says we're freaks
mutants you chose this over us and you
ruined us daddy and then she says the
iconic
and famous line no more mutants
everything goes white and the world
seemingly goes back to normal however
millions of mutants have lost their
powers now a lot of people think that we
could actually see
a reverse situation of this in the one
division series instead of wanda getting
rid of mutants she could create them
and this could perhaps be how the
mutants enter the mcu
but that's a story for another day
ultimately the mutants would get their
powers back
and wanda's twin boys would end up being
reincarnated and eventually her
and her two twin boys wiccan and speed
would be reunited and would be a family
and these are the stories that the wanda
vision series is going to be based off
of
and that means we can expect to see a
lot of crazy
things wanda discovering the true witch
side of her nature using witchcraft her
finding vision
him coming back to life and the two of
them having a family wanda warping
reality which we already know is going
to happen thanks to the teaser that they
showed us
and then the possibility of her losing
her kids and possibly having a mental
breakdown
so as you can see there is a lot to look
forward to with this series it's going
to be very very exciting based off of
these four comic book runs so let me
know what you think about these stories
and let me know how you would like to
see
the one division series play out on the
disney plus show let me know what you
think in the comments down below
don't forget to like this video and
subscribe to stay up to date on
everything relating to the mcu don't
forget to follow me on instagram and
twitter for more funko pop
giveaways and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof
you